China is presenting an increasingly
tough face to the world India has been
really shaken up by this conflict for
China and Chinese tech companies India
is the crucial testing ground even
before this clash India had been
increasingly concerned about its yawning
trade deficit with China in June the
Indian and Chinese armies engaged in a
brutal clash in a remote Himalayan
border region between them this really
shocked the whole of Asia and beyond a
me how's it looking from your side has
this all blown over now or is it still
very much a live issue in India things
have not blown over at all in fact the
two sides are engaged in a massive
military buildup along their disputed
border with tens of thousands of men
heavy machinery equipment weapons
it's the biggest military buildup in the
border area since the two countries
fought war in 1962 this is also having
major ramifications in New Delhi India
has been really shaken up by this
conflict and they are rethinking every
aspect of their relationship with China
including what had been a very rapidly
going economic relationship
[Music]
I think the commercial relationship
between India and China is going to be
one of the key areas of concern Chinese
technology companies in particular have
poured billions of US dollars into
Indian startups and other Indian tech
companies over the past few years in
fact last year alone Chinese tech
companies and new venture capital funds
that back them poured in more than three
billion u.s. dollars so this point
really can't be overstated for China and
Chinese tech companies India is the
crucial testing ground for whether it's
big companies can really grow
internationally there are two key
concerns here for the future one is
whether Indian companies will be willing
to accept Chinese money and Chinese
cooperation going forward and the second
big concern is whether Chinese companies
and the big Chinese funds will feel
secure enough to continue investing in
the Indian market we've already seen
signs of India trying to take policy
decisions that will hit at Chinese
companies there's been a slow-rolling of
customs clearance of Chinese imports at
the ports and airports and India has
announced a ban on 59 high-profile
Chinese apps including the video sharing
platform tick-tock in recent years India
has been increasingly dependent on
Chinese imports for a variety of
critical items including pharmaceutical
raw ingredients components for its
low-cost mobile phone industry
automotive industry components and this
had led to a huge feeling of dependence
on China and at the same time India has
struggled to be able to export into
China it finds the market quite
impenetrable and in services which are
areas where India does have strong
competitive advantage China really shuts
it out or kept Indian companies at a
bare minimum I think at this point in
time in the wake of this border clash
India is really really a ting everything
and asking itself whether it can afford
to be so dependent
on a country for both capital and
critically strategic imports like
pharmaceutical ingredients and telecoms
equipment if that country is hostile to
it it doesn't seem logical for China now
to be wanting to stir up passions within
India already China's relationship with
many of the key players in the world are
at a low ebb the u.s. relationship is at
its lowest point since the 1970s ties
with the European Union are strained and
similarly with much of the Western world
in Asia
China's assertiveness in the South China
Sea is alienating at least half of
Southeast Asia
so the question as to why is really key
I think my answer would be twofold first
of all it should be recognized there's a
possibility that this was a case of
overreach by a local commander on the
border in this disputed area between
India and China but that has to be said
against the fact that for several years
now the Chinese military has been
pushing and encroaching into the Indian
part of this disputed border region so
perhaps it wasn't as accidental as some
people are saying I think the other
point is probably the key point here and
that is that more and more China's
relationship with the outside world is
being defined by the security state at
home we've had about 40 years of
engagement between China and the outside
world this has been a period of great
enrichment for the Chinese economy and
for all the countries that have engaged
with China economically through trade
and investment but now it seems more and
more that it is the security agencies in
Beijing that are calling the shots and
it is their version of
an engagement that we're beginning to
see more and more of in other words
China is presenting an increasingly
tough face to the world a tough face of
a rising power that wants to be taken
more seriously on its own terms well I
know that for India this really came as
a complete surprise India now feels that
it's really at a critical moment where
if it yields and allows these Chinese
encroachments or what it sees as these
Chinese encroachments to stand that it
will be setting itself up for you know
China to just think that it can have its
way so I think India feels that it's
really kind of an existential crisis in
fact many people I speak to express
concern about the possibility of another
flare-up or further conflict just
because the situation is so tense until
now India's traditional foreign policy
stance has always been one of
non-alignment India's current Prime
Minister Narendra Modi uses a Sanskrit
phrase of India's foreign policy
approach it translates to the world as
one families
India has been growing much closer to
the u.s. in recent decades but at the
same time it has really tried to avoid
being pigeon-holed as some kind of ally
of the u.s. India has always been
cognizant of any statements that it
makes trying not to antagonize China but
in the recent years I think in the last
year particularly India has felt that
its efforts to be very sensitive towards
China's concerns have not been matched
and I think now in the wake of this
border clash this first deadly border
class since 1975 India may finally shift
from this position of let's be friends
with everyone so it seems from what
you're saying Amy is if one of the big
risks for China is that as China becomes
the world's rising superpower and as it
becomes more assertive in its foreign
relations it could end up rather than a
bouncing its interests it could end up
building an international coalition
against it
India will also be getting a lot closer
to some of the other countries in the
region that have strategic concerns with
China particularly Australia and Japan
and I think now that will come more out
in the open
there's a group called the quad which is
Australia Japan India and the US some
policymakers believe that India will
become more actively and openly involved
in quad activities and will basically
finally choose a side